malgré la distance et la pandémie qui
les sépare la mise en scène virtuelle et
bien coordonnées tout pour donner
l'impression d'un tête à tête chaleureux
nous n'avons pas d'amis plus proche que
le canada dit le président américain
le leadership des états unis nous a
cruellement manqué dit justin trudeau
échange de politesses entre les deux
voisins comme cette référence au passé
montréalais de la vice-présidente
envoyer le signal d'une amitié renouvelé
et quoi de mieux comme symbole que
l'enjeu du climat avec la promesse de
coordonner leurs efforts pour atteindre
la carboneutralité d'ici 2050 véhicule
électrique transmission d'énergie propre
plusieurs idées sont sur la table
le président et moi avons discuté de
l'importance d'une croissance propres
afin de créer de nouvelles opportunités
pour les canadiens et les américains et
un appui taille que le canada espérait
ardemment tout cas le président
américain promet de travailler à la
libération des deux canadiens détenus en
chine
les deux leaders se garde bien d'étaler
d'autres questions épineuses sur la
place publique
pas question de laisser le canada
s'approvisionner dans les doses de
vaccin contre la copie 19 produites aux
états unis avec un demi million de morts
la priorité de la maison blanche est de
vacciner tous les amériques a d'abord
pas un mot non plus sur les règles
protectionnistes buy american renforcée
par joe biden ni sur de possibles
exemption pour le canada
c'est un processus de négociations et ou
de réaction quand quelque chose qui nous
affecte jusqu'à présent ça va bien plus
qu'une bonne relation
l'opposition réclame des garanties
souvenons nous il ya cinq ans il était
le plus grand tennis barack obama mais
sa stricte marié données en entente
commerciale pour le ton est donné la
feuille de route est établie mais ottawa
devra prouver
et que cette bonne relation sera payant
à long terme qu'au delà des bonnes
intentions des gains réels attendre le
canada ici louis blouin radio canada